you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest coms
tactics training I'm going to try three
puzzles and just share my thoughts along
the way here so puzzle one of three team
white okay my first thought is that we
have even material and that there's a
lot of tension on d5 hmm checking moves
first there's a Bishop f4 check okay I
don't know what that really amounts to
well I could lead to something if the
king is flushed to the corner then that
Reno's potential back rank mates what
more oh yeah there's probably something
with that isn't there there's maybe a
three as an idea hmm okay so candidate
moves our Bishop f4 check rook takes d5
if rook takes d5 black is forced to
capture with the rook as otherwise Queen
takes bishop let me look at this one
first I will go back to Bishop f4 maybe
but I'm kind of leaning towards rook
takes on d5 rook takes d5 rook takes d5
as a follow-up what could I do
well this is another checking move I was
just kind of focusing on Bishop f4 for
the checking moves but this is another I
doubt that there's something with that
though
so if rook takes d5 rook takes d5 and as
a follow-up mm if you do a3 the bishop
moves so you take the Queen the rook
recaptures I'm not sure where you go
from there
however however I think I might be on to
something with that brief little thought
their rope takes d5 rook takes d5 as
soon as this rook is recapturing this
back rank is vulnerable and so if now
Bishop f4 where does the King go if the
King goes to the corner well let me
first point out if Bishop blocks then
you could just capture it immediately or
take the Queen the rook would
essentially be overloaded rook takes on
d5 rook takes d5 Bishop f4 check if the
bishop is blocking the rook from d5
would have two jobs to dart and defend
the Queen and the bishop so that
wouldn't be good for black however after
rook takes d5 rook takes d5 Bishop f4
check black can
well if black moves to the corner then I
know what we could be doing we could
take the rook and then if Queen takes
rook here on e8 followed by mate so rook
takes d5 rook takes d5 Bishop f4 check
would force King to c8 and then
well there's new possibilities isn't
there at that point for checks like a
rook to c1 or a queen to c2 hmm
you know what there might actually be
something with the move order of course
I was thinking about rook takes d5 rook
takes d5 and then Bishop f4 but what
about Bishop f4 immediately with still
two rooks on the board coming closer
towards the centres probably that much
more risky I think it is this checking
move first Bishop f4 check King here
then we take on d5
the rook takes then you take on d5 with
the Queen followed by mate
so Bishop f4 check it seems as if king
c8 would then be needed in which case
you could then do what you could then
give check on c2 with the Queen and if
the king is coming to d7 you take the
rook with check Queen takes and then
rook d1 with the pin and then win of the
Queen however after Bishop f4 check King
C a queen C to check what if the rook
blocks do I have a good answer to that
I'm not so sure
oh actually what might be available is
the Queen coming down here to f7 you
know let me let me back up for a second
when Bishop f4 King c8 rook c1 check
seems very appealing oh yeah that must
be it
okay yeah Bishop f4 king c8 rook c1
check if rook blocks you take the rook
with check Bishop takes is impossible
well it's possible but you lose the
Queen and if the Queen is recapturing on
c5 then rook c1 a pin and then win of
the Queen okay so I think this is it
I've spent enough time let's see if I'm
right I'm right okay in king c8 and i
guess just for coming over to see one
let's go with it that is correct and
rook blocks you just take it's the most
forcing move and then after that the pin
I think let me just make sure I've come
I've come this far don't get it wrong
now all right that was it
and let me just bring up the analysis
board to quickly show that other
variation where if the King went to the
corner thinking huh I think I have it
all now I just make sure there we go
that should be right pretty good there
so rook takes this was the initial
position check if the King goes to the
corner then there's this if Queen takes
you take the bishop rook takes you take
here and then main soon enough and if
the the order the thing that I was
stumped on initially do you take on d5
we give the check first while taking on
d5 first rook takes Bishop check now
notice there's one less piece to cause
the black king some trouble for if now
let's say check the rook blocks you take
here and now there's one less piece
around to finally get over there and
execute the final move of a pin and then
win of the Queen so move order matters
as is often the case in chess all right
let's try one more actually two more
problem - okay team white down a queen
but it feels like there should be a
mating net and there is I think I see it
mate in three it's all forcing moves all
right let's go straight with the
checking moves f4 check King here's the
only move
g4 check keen h4 is the only move and
then finally Bishop f2 mate
I don't think I've miscalculated there
let me just double-check
is there something quicker than a
million three or did I mess up with that
initial calculation is the only thing
that I'm concerned about I kind of
wonder how this night got here and the
chlorine got stuck in the corner but
okay matin three puzzle I'm pretty sure
this turns out to be have four check
King here only move g4 check King h4 on
the move and then the bishop drops back
might be a little bit difficult to
visualize that but these different
pieces moving there's there's in this
final move the pawn won't be on f2 the
spawn won't be on g3 which makes the
bishop able to give me with Bishop f2
all right I'm pretty sure that's it it's
correct check check and it goes no
further but we could see we don't have
to go into the analysis King h4 is met
with Bishop f2 and that's game over all
right let's see if what you know three
four three last one oh this is gonna
require calculation I hate that I hate
that calculation stuff okay well white
better have something up his sleeve
because down a lot of material there but
this pawn is super dangerous okay so
okay checking those why not if you give
a check here but this allows came to e4
one of my thoughts that I have right now
is is it possible for white to even win
it might be some no I wasn't for a
second this thing is there some
perpetual check with like a knight
bouncing back and forth the King is a
bit limited like if there was a black on
on e4 or really
any piece that wouldn't be checking the
white king you promote and after the RIP
takes if it did take 97 would be mate so
night on a night on d7 would guard he 5
f6 is their way however to do something
about controlling e4 you can come over
here with your king but then this King
picks up a pond and has a bunch of other
new safe squares to run to all right so
what is it hmm
night check it seems like an interesting
start but what is the great follow up
after if 97 check King e4 what in the
world do you think you're gonna do now
oh I think I see something you know what
it is it's gonna be a stalemate White's
gonna get stalemated how did I just see
that I don't have it I'm not certain but
what I was just seeing is that after
this night check King here this Bishop
is now controlling these two squares and
this is important because now there's
gonna be a follow up move of Knight f6
check if the knight is not taken the
knight place to g8 which will pave the
way for h8 promotion to a queen next or
very soon thereafter and if it is taken
if the knight is taken well now you
promote to a queen and after rook takes
there is now no safe Square for the
kingdom move to and interestingly enough
when the knight does play to f6 and is
captured now this pawn is not able to
move when the king is on e4 this pawn is
not able to move so this is what it is
white cannot win it's the first thing to
recognize I probably should have
recognized that much sooner to be honest
because this rook could always come over
here if this Knight isn't isn't going to
be able to give me and he isn't there's
a dark square and a light square the
knight is
able to control both color complexes so
this rook if you can't stop them from
getting the H a and you really can't
then the best white could really do is
to try for some draw or in this case is
stalemate
so that's sad I'm pretty sure this is
the first move ninety seven let me just
double check ninety-seven check Rupp
takes white promotes to Queen
so 97 King e for this pawn is not able
to move this Bishop is now guarding g3
of the relevant relevant squares g3 to
be covered Knight to f6 check that is a
cool move if the knight is not captured
to go to g8 if he is captured this pawn
is now around to guard g5 and then you
promote rook takes all these squares g v
g3
covered the king is the black king would
be guarding these two and the rook has
the other three I'll be stalemate
alright let's run with it and it's
correct I'm pretty sure this is it -
that is correct
and finally you promote Queen and that's
it it doesn't have to go any further
let's just bring this up quick analysis
board King takes this was the initial
position check if rip takes we're just
promoting black doesn't want that so he
runs here check if you do something else
like this there's Knight g8 and he's
gonna be promoting soon so you can't
allow that pawn takes his best promote
rook here and that's stalemate pawns
here the guard g5 the bishops here to
guard g3 no legal moves alright
went three for three I don't know if I
did that it's been a while since I did
that I think but feel free to share how
you did with these and I'll catch you in
the next video take care bye
you